what is the
quote like like what is like the for you
you know if you get off your head a lot
that means you turn down a lot of head
right yeah
so what would make you want to turn down
the head if it's a is a girl not pretty
is she
her teeth her teeth um
her shoes i look at their shoes their
feet
um things like that i look at their
mouth their feet
just make sure they look like they're
taking care of gotta be depends on what
mood i'm in also
so what what shoes are a no-go like if a
[__] has these shoes on
like what if a [__] got timberlands on
uh timberland's not that bad not that
bad all right especially if you're in
new york
especially if you're in new york you
might you might be sexy with them tim
okay yeah but uh you can't have no dirty
ass voices on
some dirty forces what about some black
forces
can't have no [__] um the wrong
jaw and john
you can't have a mexican jar the team to
team jordan's
team [__] you ain't hitting this
[__]
yo that's so funny because we all be
about hobbies are always we gotta we got
a friend we have them team job you gonna
[__] can't fly around
you gotta have the retros where the team
door hey you know
me and freddie gibbs were in texas and
uh we had a homie named brian moses
who's a real real big comedian
and he had the most busted down team
jordans on the entire trip
and he's he was he swear he was rocking
them [__] though
you know what i'm saying they're like
bro those are the mexican jays for sure
them team jordans ain't it so a [__]
pulls up with some team j's
some dirty forces i'm smoking cigarettes
or smoking cigarettes i don't want you
to suck i don't want my dick smelling
like